since President Trump decided to walk
away from the Iran nuclear deal and may
have last year tensions between our two
nations have steadily increased
punishing economic sanctions have been
reimpose but while those sanctions are
intended to hurt the Iranian government
everyday people are also paying a price
emptiest i'am got a rare look inside
iran and spoke with some of those
affected after hours of negotiations we
were finally given permission by iranian
authorities to travel aboard this
fishing boat steering us deep into
Iran's maritime territory the view from
here may seem peaceful but make no
mistake these waters are an
international flashpoint that has
everyone in the region on edge 20
year-old Mohammad has been trawling the
Strait of Hormuz since he was a little
boy
along with his uncle and nephew they
worked the same waters their family has
for generations are you worried that an
accident the mistake could happen and we
see a fight between Americans and Iran
this waterway is vital not just for
Muhammad but for the world on any given
day around 1.3 billion dollars worth of
crude passes through the Strait and
Iran's Navy chief says any threat to
Iranian interests would lead to an
all-out war but war isn't on the minds
of most Iranian a terrible state that
the economy is here in the local market
people are really feeling the pinch much
like millions of Iranians across the
country in the years since President
Trump began reimposing what his
administration is calling the
toughest-ever sanctions on Iran over the
past 12 months the price of staples like
chicken are up by almost 80% even the
humble tomato is 5 times more expensive
but it's the real the Iranian currency
which has hit pocketbooks the hardest
after being devalued to an all-time low
all this uncertainty worries math are
poor and his wife Satan what are you
more worried about the economy or the
we award the economy wish I was dying
because she's saying I worry I'm worried
I'm bringing about the war back in
Tehran at the Abdul Azim shrine hundreds
of worshippers are here for Friday
prayers and more often than not to
listen to fiery anti-american sermons
but this time the Imams speech was
decidedly muted other issues clearly
weighing on the minds of worshippers
issues that are also weighing heavily
elsewhere including at hospitals where
caring for the country's most vulnerable
is becoming increasingly difficult Iran
produces most of its own medicines but
when it comes to the most advanced
pharmaceuticals it relies heavily on
imports and that's how sanctions can
have an effect imported pharmaceuticals
have dropped by 80% in recent months and
the cost for the tiny amount of drugs
that do make it in has skyrocketed a
reality that only adds to the agony felt
by four-year-old Matty's parents who've
just learned his cancer is back and the
cocktail of drugs he needs to stay alive
simply aren't available are people
losing their lives because they can't
get this drug yes what do you say to a
parent whose child has cancer that
the drug is available outside of Iran
but you can't bring it into Iran what do
you say to them I just send them to pray
and be sure that we are with you we know
your pain stark reminder that in Iran
nearly every aspect of life is affected
by US sanctions for CBS this morning
Saturday in Thea's tyub Tehran fantastic
reporting by MTS and his team there and
a reminder that you can talk about
something on a diplomatic level but if
you go to the street level and examine
exactly what's happening there and in
other places that's really the best way
to look at it and most of all or the
worst is yeah it's the most vulnerable
hurt by them yeah politics is personal